kelly 32 years old he's a 30 year old
rookie in 2019
interesting career path anyhow this is
what he features a fastball about 92
miles an hour he'll think he'll cut it
curveball is a plus pitch for him a lot
of ground balls a lot of swings and
misses with that curveball change up a
good offering as well five and seven for
the 446 era for merrill kelly
the 1-1
is bounced to the right side that's amen
as he handles that chance and one up and
one down
so here's kb now as kelly
back to work delivers
and that one is hit hard but out of
bounds collected by ahmed
and the wrong guy to try
javier three for nine in the series
kelly comes back 0-2
via swings and misses strike three it
took only seven pitches for kelly to
work one two three in the first inning
we check in with the zak
sinker change up heavy usage of that
change up occasional curveball and
cutter five and six with a four point
three seven era this is start number
twenty
slender right-hander yeah the pitch to
calhoun
that's drilled to center but right at
marisna
right there baristic and a good start
for zach davies as he picks off rojas
and it's the center fielder jake
mariznick up there
and he sends one out to right center
diving catch by cole calhoun
what a play
oh that's a pitcher's best friend there
calhoun has one gold glove he's always a
finalist in the gold glove race and he
gets a really good jump on this ball off
the bat of marisnick gets over leaves
his feet and makes an outstanding play
boy what a play great to have him top of
the order again here's rizzo
and rizzo gets one to right
back on it goes calhoun still going back
and
he made the catch again well he almost
matched the first one he got
and he took a hit away from marisnick
back in the second and then he robbed
rizzo here
of one going deep into that corner and
right field lunch for it made the catch
and then braced himself against the
fence two on the other he's something
special and he really has not gotten it
going as far as the batting average only
two home runs too he hit 19 a couple of
years ago that ball's ripped to right on
the run though hayward and back and he
can't get it all over his head and uh
against the fence out there and ahmed
into second base
that one must take it off on jason
looked like he had a play on it and all
of a sudden the last second leap you're
not really expecting ahmed to hit the
ball that aggressively to the opposite
field and i think hayward got caught
varsho hitting 148
swings and rolls one to the right side
nice fundamental play by varsho it
advances the runner to third with only
one away as baez throws him out at first
and now you've got the pitcher coming up
swinging a miss change up strike three
swung and missed out number two
strikeout number three for davies comes
on the changeup rojas had a base on
balls and immediately was picked off
first in the first inning i guess he's
not swinging 3-0
you are correct sir there's a second
walk for rojas and now it's cole calhoun
around the corner with two outs
he hits a smash
shallow right glove by horner on the
outfield grass throws him out to end the
enemy
nice job by davies the uh diamondbacks
had the lead off doubled by ahmed but he
never scored
we go to inning number four now patrick
wisdom who has their hit he led up the
second i think with a single to left
a little swinging butt on it has to
hurry bare-handed
[Applause]
how about this defense today we talk
about him being a wizard with the glove
that time he used the bare hand and
threw accurately off balance a strike
over to walker a chance to put a big
crooked number up there right here
escobar is at third walker at second
peralta's at first and that ball is
ripped away to base it one will score
they'll stay loaded as hayward throws to
the plate on the hop perfectly thrown
but diamondbacks get the lead on the
live single the right off the bat of
pavement smith it's one-nothing d-backs
fbi number 29 for smith and now the
payoff pitch on the way a bouncing ball
toward the middle buyers has it steps on
second throws to first double play to
end the inning you mentioned he was a
double play candidate ron and that's
exactly what the cubs get martial hit a
sharp rounder right up the middle but
baez was stationed right behind the bag
rbi spot right here a ball and a strike
swinging a live drive that's a hit to
right phil that's going to score rojas
make it two nothing on an rbi single by
cole calhoun rbi number six for cole
once he got it by nico horner there was
no way in the world they were gonna get
rojos nice hooking line drive base hit
two nothing game bases loaded two outs
three and two the count on the batter
pavement smith ryan delivers the pitch
ground ball right side picked up by
soulguard he flips it to first in time
to get smith and ryan gets the cubs out
of the gym so they limit the damage to
just one run so man at third cubs down
by a couple and bryant-o for two merrell
kelly's pitch lying down the right field
line chasing the ball in the corner and
not getting it that ball is up against
the wall bouncing away a run will score
bryant will
leg to second
and he's got a double cubs are on the
board he almost homered
right down the line and right now the
cubs just a blooper away from a tie ball
game and the pitch on the way to bias
swing and a line drive base it left
field bryant's going to try to score
here comes the throw to the plate it is
going to be
not in time bryant scores the tying run
and down to second goes by as the ball
game is tied at two and the cub fans
at chase field are loving it and the 1-0
pitch to calhoun swinging a ground ball
rizzo's got it he'll throw home and it's
in time
the force play at the plate good play by
anthony now a throw to first base did
calhoun
jump off the bag or did he never get to
the bag i don't think calhoun ever runs
through the base he gets out of the way
of rizzo's throw
going home and then they throw to first
base did calhoun forget how many ouchs
there were chorinos calls time their
gains and still going on though then to
throw to first base and this should be a
double play one of the more bizarre
double plays i've ever seen and once
again the diamondbacks have a bases
loaded opportunity
little tapper stays fair cerinos is on
it
and escobar is home it's three to two
would just be big for barshow if you get
a hit here first one to him is off the
plate here comes the runner to score on
a wild pitch i wouldn't care if it was a
block a wild pitch or whatever but the
diabetes got another run they played a
two in the ending and that lead at three
to one here's the ground ball right side
it'll be scooped up by sogar throws to
rizzo almost threw it away anthony
lunging into foul territory to grab it
and step on the back to end the end
three infielders on the right side
against rizzo
who skies it to center for pavon smith
merrill kelly has done it again three
outs on eight pitches edwardo has walked
twice and scored twice over two
escobar slams it deep to left field and
war though escobar it's gone
escobar de la fica that's number 21 and
it's six to two merrill kelly back out
there for the ninth at 75 pitches and
the 1-1
pious hits a bullet and it's into right
field of base hit bryant around third
heading home
the throw will be cut off as bryant
scores baya is a run-scoring single
merrill kelly will not get the complete
game here and once again sorry is one
out away here's a 3-2
and a live drive base hit their ball
and that's going to get into the
left-field corner baez in to score
ortega delivers again off the bench so
contreras who was the hero yesterday in
the late stages again here today carl
strike three got him and a win for
merrell kelly joaquin soria walked a
high wire but this time he made it
across